[Musique]
sophie salvat en scène en troisième
année à l'école primaire d'iberville sur
la rive sud de montréal
[Musique]
lorsque ces élèves sont moins attentifs
elle propose un cours exercices qui les
aident à se recentrer la trotteuse vous
demander de vous concentrer pour
entendre seulement le tic tac de
l'horloge haute attention ta respiration
peau au voisin importe attention à ce
que toi sur ce 1 3 minutes de présence
attentive trois minutes de respiration
et de concentration sur le moment
présent
le bourricot le tic-tac fait et ça va
avec une grosse échappée multi tactile
carter et mon coeur fait boum
bienvenue dans le monde de la méditation
pleine conscience
aujourd'hui la classe de se fie à des
invités spéciaux de chercheurs en
psychologie de l'université du québec
elles viennent voir comment les enfants
réagissent aux exercices de leurs
programmes de présence attentive encore
à l'étude
ça file même dans ma bulle subi cheville
et qui j'aime 1,5 et personnes autour de
moi chez julien puis je te donnerai
depuis 2014 on a eu plusieurs études
pilotes qui t'ont donné des résultats
encourageants notamment pour diminuer
l'anxiété la dépression
l'inattention l'agressivité puis en
global ans pour améliorer le climat
classe à autre chose que des problèmes
puis de me fâcher
puis je me sens bien aussi forte à pékin
ce qui t'as remarqué les effets comme
immédiat car celui de tuer leur
l'exercice de la trotteuse par exemple
dans la classe est ce que ça change
quelque chose
bon déjà dû comme qui ressemble comme
les épaules sobeys lot c'est samedi que
la tension diminue
6 antique je me détends des feuilles et
un bel exercice sur les pensées les
émotions plus les sensations physiques
alexane fait partie du groupe de
recherche elle vient former les
enseignants comme sophie pour qu'ils
deviennent de bons guides avons fait
pour leur faire comprendre que la
méditation en fait c'est pas de la
relaxation ce pot tout à fait la même
chose
oui on peut relaxer mais l'objectif
principal c'est juste de savoir qui
d'observer ce qui se passe sans jugement
ben nous penser c'est un peu comme ça
dans nos têtes des fois c'est la tempête
qui on a de la misère à se concentrer de
plus en plus les élèves les différentes
problématiques à la maison iv beaucoup
de pièces allant nous les enseignants on
essaie de se trouver des nouvelles
stratégies pour essayer que les élèves
ils vivent mieux leur réalité
quotidienne
[Musique]
au canada un enfant du primaire sur cinq
éprouve des difficultés liées à
l'inattention l'hyperactivité l'anxiété
ou la dépression
face à cette détresse psychologique une
nouvelle tendance s'installe dans les
écoles à présence attentive favorise une
meilleure gestion du stress
puis une meilleure gestion de ses
propres émotions ou c'est calme dans ta
tête
c'est vraiment une pratique très très
simple en tout ce qu'on veut en fait
c'est d'aider l'enfant à porter
attention à ce qui se passe en ce moment
à l'intérieur de lui manque ses
sensations physiques ses pensées
[Musique]
je regarde cette chose très curieuse
dans ta main
que tu ne connais pas observé avec les
cinq sens prend d'une distance de ses
pensées et lorsque l'esprit vagabonde
ramener sa concentration sur un objet
choisi aujourd'hui la pomme quoi ça tu
fais penser tu vas peut-être la
rapprocher de ton oeil parce que tu te
ment est-ce que ça fait du bruit staff
arles
et maintenant tout peut croquer dedans
l'exercice de la pomme fait partie d'une
panoplie d'expériences uniques qui aide
les enfants à développer leur attention
même si c'est une pratique quotidienne
de 3 5 minutes par jour en moyenne
il faut que ça soit quand même presque
quotidiens pour que ça a un impact est
ce que tu te sentir à l'aise de
reprendre le programme final de l'animé
lanta crans we shall est une femme les
élèves la même source
sahamies qui j'en fais beaucoup parce
que j'aime ça des élèves calme épanouie
et concentré une responsabilité qui
s'ajoutent pour les enseignants est-ce
que ça bouffe du temps classe bouffer du
temps de classe on peut penser qu oui
mais c'est du temps en fait qu'on
économise parce qu'on vous - crise ont
mis plus d'un quart les élèves sont
plusieurs
[Musique]
je pense que ça devrait être implanté de
plus en plus dans les écoles
quand il pleut
[Musique]
tu peux revenir à nyon
et on va terminer la méditation
[Applaudissements]